If cells didn't double their DNA before dividing, then every
time they divided they would cut their genome in half
from 46 chromosomes to 23 in each daughter cell. All
the chromes would line up in pairs and then separate in
a way that each daughter cell would only get one
of those chromosomes. Think about how bad this would be
for trying to keep genetic consistency in all your cells.
You'd have one mother cell here that's heterozygous for lactose metabolism.
We have a dominant and a recessive allele, one
on each chromosome. There's no duplication of DNA. So, after
cell division occurs, then each daughter cell would only end
up with one chromosome. And think about it, because of
the heterozygous nature of the mother cell, each daughter cell
is going to have a different genotype, a different genetic makeup.
One will have the dominant allele for lactase persistence, and
the other will have the recessive allele for lactase non-persistence.
This would mean you'd have cells in your body
that end up with different genotypes and different phenotypes.
Therefore, before every cell division, the DNA would be
duplicated. And that way, when cell division occurs, each
daughter cell ends up with the same amount that
the mother cell originally had before duplication. So just
to make sure we're on the same page here.
If DNA duplication does occur, how many chromosomes will
each daughter cell have? Again, assume equal division,
and put your numerical answer in this box here.